[Music]
making it in the world of streaming is
no small task there are thousands and
thousands of content creators going live
at any given time obviously hard work
hours of dedication and a bit of luck is
at the core of finding success in
anything but with this particular craft
you need something more an x factor that
sets you apart from the crowd
it can be anything from your stream
overlay to the overall production value
of your setup i have someone that you
can meet okay
okay let's see it
oh no
wait what is that
the fact is these days raw skill and
talent alone aren't enough to take you
to the upper echelon of streaming or
is it you see in the annals of apex
legends skill has almost always been
more respected than anything else and
for good reason among the top tier
battle royale shooters out there it's
one of the most competitive and
demanding and perhaps no one embodies
that more than shivam shiv fps patel a
shield cracking smoke pushing madman
who's interested in one thing and one
thing only gaming
[Music]
hard i'm just appealing
yeah
i'm watching watching
okay i'm going around going around
protect him
dead
what the [ __ ] is happening
oh my god that team got destroyed shiv
isn't just your average streamer
sweating it out in ranked for those
sweet content clicks no he's taken his
seemingly insatiable bloodlust and
turned it into both a trademark and a
competitive career
just kill them
dead
weight dead laugh
over here
pushing pushing for you
don't flash
so
how exactly did shiv earn his title as
apex's solo q warlord how did that
moniker make him one of the scene's most
impractical esports stars and how has
his passion for the game
occasionally gotten him into some
trouble you only get 1k damage with
cheats or mega lol trash only six kills
with cheese trash trash trash only 1k
damage with cheats i can do that
blindfolded you dumb mother
holy [ __ ] you only get 6k kills with
gamebot yup
trash
all right guys before we get into the
video i'm hoping you can take a moment
if you haven't already to like the video
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification bell it's like uh squatting
up on youtube or something
right okay so among the endless sea of
talented streamers who favor battle
royales our boy shiv stands out as a bit
of an enigma while off the server he
doesn't take himself all that seriously
you'll have a hard time finding a
sweatier competitor on it
man
god damn it i hate these players these
are the fakest
players i've ever seen in my life also
where most streamers always play nice
with their audience for the financial
perks it brings shiv isn't exactly known
for pulling punches on his chat when he
disagrees with them this is why i don't
like when people in twitch chat say yo
shiv you missed this you missed that you
missed this i don't give a [ __ ] i played
to win fights not to loot so so don't be
dumb and don't go into people's chat and
say yo you missed this you missed that
shut
let them play let them win the fight and
although shiv is one of the most
exciting apex players out there his
absolute eternity spent solo queuing
doesn't always help him play nicely with
strangers one day you'll be good at apex
but today is not that day cause you
landed the worst most dog [ __ ] yes spots
i've ever seen in the history of my life
because you're bonds i don't know who
boosted you to master you must have
bought like a boosting service or
something because you are not master
there is no way your skill level is even
equivalent to a buns jesus christ
anyway before he was berating scrubs and
clapping copious cheeks as the solo q
warlord
how did shiv get his start well this
lively lad with luscious locks actually
hails from leicester england he first
began streaming back in 2016 with call
of duty black ops 2. and from there he
dabbled in a wide variety of games like
fortnite h1z1 and escape from tarkov but
it was when apex legends released in
february 2019 that everything changed
for shiv apex was fast it was frantic
and it rewarded positional awareness and
as he poured more and more hours into it
it became clear that the game fit him
like a glove
now of course as is the case with many
streamers not every challenge shiv faced
was on the server and as he told gfinity
his mom was especially concerned about
him spending time on twitch instead of
pursuing a more traditional career path
but as shiv's collection of clip-worthy
highlights continued to grow and with it
his following his mom's apprehensions
loosened especially by january of 2020
when he was signed by luminosity gaming
as a content creator over the course of
the next year shiv's star continued to
rise meteorically and while it was his
insane gameplay that initially brought
fans on board it was his increasingly
ferocious personality that kept them
coming back for more
[Music]
soon enough thanks to his exceedingly
savage beatdowns and spicy pop-offs shiv
became more than shiv he was a
blood-thirsty bangalore-repping
berserker who simply became known to his
fans as the solo q warlord
come on
come on
do something
come on please shoot them guys please
push out and shoot them push out and
shoot them please fight them fight them
guys fight them
for the love of god team fight them
kill him kill him but for shiv solo
queueing isn't just a content driver
it's also an unorthodox training ground
you see when he's not streaming for
luminosity he regularly competes on a
team known as the solo cute goats and
strangely instead of practicing together
he and his fellow sadists dif q and
zippeth largely prepare for tournaments
individually the best part is as batshit
as that approach sounds it's actually
yielded some surprisingly successful
results in the algs
i'm with you
guys
[Music]
push it push it
give me one give me that one guys put
that shield up shut up
one day
i need to go i need to go let's go
let's
go take that man now of course when
you're relying on solo queue to create
content
and prepare for high-stakes tournaments
there are going to be some challenges
especially in apex which has developed
notoriety for being a breeding ground
for the unethical and if there's one
thing that the solo queue warlord will
not tolerate it's a dirty cheater
i'm just dude he's a bangalore
i am getting bullied by ship's hot
sister jesus
christ
if that's not stream sniping i don't
know what is
ah he died with cheats
we are very sorry
my god man
oh
if audio isn't bad enough in this game
then you have aim butters but at the
center of shiv's battle for fair play
has been one recurring villain and
that's apex legend's most notorious
cheater
toofy nice
well i guess he's packed everyone's
account and can talk to us now in game
oh mega lo holy [ __ ] what
what the [ __ ] literally got a chat
message in my game from the hackers
are you
bro i got that too yeah maybe it is
tuffy doing all this over the past year
whether it's been copycats or the same
person this whole time tufy always seems
to find a way into shiv's matches
although sometimes he probably wishes he
didn't
protect him
you're so trash you're so
trashy you're so [ __ ] josh oh my god
now as satisfying as these sweet sweet
moments of revenge might be
there is a downside you see shiv's
animated reactions to cheaters like
tuffy hasn't just resulted in him being
targeted more it's also seen him get
punished for taking his retaliations too
far
your
trash your
trash your [ __ ] trash
[Applause]
i hope you die
[ __ ]
making matters worse tuffy isn't just
interfering with shiv's matches he's
also been able to lock him out of his
own account on several occasions
preventing him from playing apex
altogether alright boys gg apex you're
finished it's over for you this game can
go sucker
you
apex
trash but as much as apex can
occasionally drive shiv up the wall
nothing can stop him or his audience
from coming back for more as of this
video's release he's built an army of
1.2 million followers on twitch who will
happily clip his every insane play and
the moments where he isn't taking
himself seriously at all
cat do you see that oil at paper at the
back it's for shiv's massive peen when
it needs to like you know stuff it takes
the whole role
at the end of the day shiv story is a
refreshing reminder that you don't need
a gimmick to make a name for yourself on
twitch through his unwavering dedication
to apex the amount of sweat he's poured
into it and his infectious charisma he's
been able to forge a reputation as not
only one of the game's most entertaining
competitors but maybe even it's most
relatable holy
yo you want me to revive you huh yeah
stop stream snipe me [ __ ]
then i'll revive you dumbass
[ __ ] you no get the [ __ ] off my game
[ __ ] it's hard to say what heights the
solo queue warlord's path of destruction
will lead him to next but until then
you'll know exactly where to find
oh him god we are disgusting
we are the best players driver play this
game oh my god where's the
best
so i started buying french's ketchup
it's better than heinz's ketchup buy
french's ketchup i'm not kidding you you
will not be disappointed you should try
french's just try it it's not it's not
like the difference between the two is
so massive that you're gonna buy a
bottle of french's ketchup and you're
gonna be like [ __ ] i can't eat this like
just buy it just try it just it's
cheaper than heinz ketchup bro
just get it